Tương em một táng bệnh năm 2018, là được lựa xinh con đẩm địa thái sản, bày kháng,
là được năm 2019, là người ngày làm việc thí vợ xinh con.
Đây là một trong những lỗi dung của lời dân số với được của hội chính thức thông qua.
Lợi cũng nếu gió sẽ có hỗ sợ tại chính khi xinh con lời với phụ nữ rất tập thiệu số rất ít người.
Hỗ sợ tại chính khi xinh con lời với phụ nữ ở tình thành phố,
có mức xin dưới mức xin thái thế và hỗ sợ tại chính khi xinh con lời với phụ nữ xin,
với khi hỗ sợ hết đúngQi của vậy mình hai còn xước bàng làm tôi.
Đặc biệt theo quy định của lời gần bơi có từ hai con lời trời lên sẽ được ưu thiền mô.
Thôi mô hoặc thuy nhạy ở sã hội.
Theo quy định của pháp lột cái nhạy ở cứu điều kiệt kịch tệ sã hội trong tượng thời gý,
chính phủ quy định mất vượn trình từ thủ tục cho các chính thách trên.
Lợ dân số đã quy định, lịch không, lịch hướng chính xách, động thể,
căn cơ, nụ chính xách là độ, điều cơ làm, tiền luôn, và hiểm sã hội, và hiểm ý tế.
Chợ cấp sảo dục trong sốc sự quay nhà ờ và chính xe khác nhằm ra tăng tỷ lệ sinh để đặt được mất sinh khai thế để bự.